a war has been going on for billions of
years that breeds well-armed monsters
who struggle with other monsters for
survival having no particular interest
in us most of them are relatively
harmless as our immune systems deal with
their weapons easily
but there are exceptions
negleria fowlery is an amoeba that has
not only developed a deadly taste for
human brains but is also a match for our
defenses and stars in dramatic headlines
what happens when this monster enters
your body
[Music]
nagleria fowlery is an amoeba a microbe
with a nucleus one of the smallest life
forms on earth
it is a voracious hunter of bacteria and
other critters that it devours whole and
rips into pieces
like many amoebi it is able to transform
into different stages that help it
survive
but most of the time negleria fowlery is
in its trophozoite stage during which it
looks like a squishy blob with tiny arms
and hunts divides and thrives
its natural home is in fresh water ponds
rivers lakes and hot springs
but unfortunately it also feels happy in
pipes swimming pools fountains or spas
when they're not properly treated
the warmer the water the more it thrives
and multiplies
so in the summer when humans seek to
cool off and enjoy themselves the
chances are highest that both species
will interact
because this makes it hard to avoid
millions of people regularly have
contact with the amoeba especially in
warmer climates and many people even
seem to have antibodies against it and
this is mostly okay you can even swallow
it without consequences
things turn bad when people dive or swim
in water contaminated with the amoeba
and water splashes high up into their
noses
in a single drop of lake water there are
millions of viruses bacteria and amoeb
and that isn't really a big deal but
nigleria fowlery is different
let's zoom into the nose of an
unsuspecting victim enjoying a great
summer day and see what happens
first of all the amoeba doesn't really
want to be inside your nose as it's not
really looking for trouble it just wants
to eat a few bacteria
instead it's greeted by your natural
defenses
unfortunately for humans the glaria
fowlery happens to be exceptionally good
at generally flying under the radar of
your immune system
for example the inside of your nose is
covered by mucosa a slime filled with
chemicals that kill or stun possible
invaders or alert immune cells
but negleria fallary is not particularly
bothered by them and instead calmly
chats out the scenery mildly annoyed
about the whole ordeal
now if you are unlucky the tiny critter
stumbles over something that actually
sparks its interest
nerve cells
your nose is filled with a large network
of olfactory nerve cells that pick up
molecules from the outside and transmit
their information to your olfactory bulb
the center of smell in your brain to do
their job these cells talk to each other
by releasing various messenger chemicals
and recognizing them via specific
receptors
one of the most important of these
chemicals is acetylcholine
through sheer evolutionary bad luck
negleria fowlery happens to have
receptors that recognize acetylcholine
and it seems to attract them
irresistibly a little like moths that
are attracted by light
so as your olfactory nerve cells do
their job using plenty of acetylcholine
to talk to the brain negleria fowlery
enters your tissue
it seems to follow the chemical signals
upstream
neutrophils crazy suicide warriors begin
to attack the amiib
individually they have no chance against
them as the invaders are large and
pretty buff fighters used to dealing
with tough enemies
so the defenders swarm the intruders and
kill them either by vomiting chemicals
that punch holes into them or by
literally ripping parts of them off and
devouring them
but the negleria fowlery train is still
on track and while the neutrophil
attacks slow them down they continue to
follow the olfactory nerves to their
final destination
your brain
this process can take between one and
nine days and you'll probably not notice
anything during that time
until the amoeb reach the olfactory bulb
the center of smell and entrance to your
brain
your brain cells are nothing more than
helpless victims and they all release
that wonderful acetylcholine
neglia fowlery initiates a massacre and
releases an onslaught of various attack
molecules
some of them are basically little bombs
that rip holes into your cells on
contact so their pieces can be eagerly
consumed
but negleria fowlery is now multiplying
and it's also becoming really creepy
in a feeding frenzy it can develop up to
a dozen suckers called food cups that
look like giant eerie mouths
the amoeba engage your brain cells suck
them in and rip large bites out of them
while they're still alive
now things escalate quickly and the
disease that will kill you sets in
alerted by the massacre millions of
immune cells neutrophils eosinophils and
microglias invade the infected tissue
which is a problem your immune system is
dangerous and not exactly a careful
fighter
it's like burning down a forest to kill
the wolves inside it a really bad idea
in the brain
they waste no time and attack the amoeba
using all the weapons available to them
from chemicals to trying to eat them
alive neutrophils explode themselves to
erect barriers spiked with deadly
chemicals
a fierce battle ensues
nagleria fowlery can actually fight back
itself attacking and killing many immune
cells
the immune system now throws everything
it has at the invader but in vain
the complement system tiny protein bombs
that can kill intruders on their own are
easily disabled
antibodies usually one of your super
weapons are just destroyed or swallowed
a high fever that usually slows enemies
down does nothing as the amoeba actually
thrives in the heat
all the while the amoeba continue to
multiply fight and devour your brain
cells
a disastrous chain reaction is taking
place
one major thing your immune cells do
when they fight is to cause inflammation
which directs large amounts of fluid
from your bloodstream into the site of
an infection
so as the battle rages on without a
clear winner more and more fluid enters
the brain
at this point the human will feel
symptoms that quickly escalate
it all begins pretty vaguely a headache
fever nausea and vomiting
as the battle spreads rapidly through
the brain serious symptoms appear from
confusion inability to concentrate to
fatigue seizures and hallucinations
the brain swells up massively but can't
expand due to the bones surrounding it
so it compresses and disables the brain
stem that controls things like breathing
usually within a week the patient dies
up to 97 of the patients infected by the
amoeba share this fate
in almost all cases by the time an
infection by negleria fowlery is
recognized the disastrous battle for the
brain is already so far along that there
is almost nothing to be done
not only do we currently not have
effective treatments there are also an
abundance of open questions about how an
amoeba that usually enjoys its life in
open water is able to overcome our
immune system so effectively
so how worried do you need to be about
this horrifying killer amoeba
well not very while the maglaria fallary
is clearly extremely deadly and the
infection truly horrible there have only
been a few hundred cases in the last few
decades
you are way more likely to drown in a
pool than to get infected
not only does the amoeba need to be
flushed high up your nose it also needs
to get a good grip and it also has to
make its way through the first lines of
your defenses
ultimately negleria fallary is neither
evil nor a huge public health risk but
every year some unlucky people have to
deal with it
we still have so much to learn about it
and until we find a way to treat it
niglaria fowlery will continue to be
this vague and horrifying thing hunting
in puddles and lakes and sometimes pools
usually for bacteria and very
occasionally
for people
[Music]
oh hey
who are you it's me
your existential dread
um
okay i'm here to make you question your
own existence in everything you hold
dear at life could you not please too
late just look at all these amazing
posters full of humbling visualizations
like the scale of the universe look how
huge it is and how small you are
look at the education edition how it
dives deep into the history of evolution
or all the other scientific fields to
make you feel bad for all the stuff you
don't know
or look at this one it glows in the dark
but dread these do make me feel good
actually they do fill me with excitement
and all about how amazing our universe
is and i love learning and look how
pretty they are no
i can't persist in the presence of allah
if you too want to overcome your
existential dread make your life
beautiful and also support codskazak so
we can put thousands of hours into our
videos and release them for free you can
get these and many many more amazing
posters or shirts or so many more things
in our shop
we put as much care into our products as
into our videos trying to find something
clever or a new angle that will
challenge your perspective while still
teaching you the core aspects it's the
best way to support what we do on this
channel
[Music]
you